[Music]
with the constant buffering of this logo
it's no surprise that this movie was
brought to us by Comcast also what
exactly is this supposed to be a ping
dial-up internet issues in 2014 this
warning notice seems way too complex
should just read warning live suicide
only dickhead should enter a level of
douchebaggery that would compel someone
to film this instead of attempting to
help might exist but I'm not willing to
deal with that thought so soon I shall
lower suicide video can't decide how
long it actually is here it seems to be
159 but when we escape full screen
somehow the time has changed to 230 also
personal requests can we please not make
any more movies that start with
realistic first-person video of suicide
thanks Hollywood you're the best I'm not
gonna lie the idea of telling an entire
story just on a computer screen is
brilliant and the movie deserves credit
for having the balls to mostly follow it
through Plus this is the usual BS movie
software these are real sites and real
videos and while the videos have been
removed these links still actually work
to this day this video has 75 thousand
741 views and not a single one of those
viewers hit the subscribe link even
accidentally I'm not saying it's
impossible but go ahead and see if you
can find a video with more than 50,000
views and no subscribers
I'll wait sound like a little oh no no
great just watching suicide videos I'm a
good friend it's just another day that
ends in Y you are now looking at the
outside of the human's right leg you
know he's just let me come over and show
you how it's done it sorry Mitch if you
want to go full cyber someday you'll
have to do the legwork first that was
the reaction Blair was looking for
really
I appreciated boobies all through high
school and it got me nowhere but add
some cheer rhyming to it and it somehow
works somehow Blair's own video gets all
hot and buffered even though we're
viewing her machines direct feet sure
maybe lowers the cause of this but
considering it'll happen throughout the
movie with no confusion on her part
here's an extra 20 sins for constant
self buffering which coincidentally
describes my entire adolescence
[Music]
what's goofy boast has to poltergeist
some miners like answering a group call
while boobs are about to be shown
instead of just killing everyone she
finds responsible for her death Ken
tries the always productive second stab
at a joke when the first one went
completely unacknowledged eases Christ
this movie should really just be called
helpdesk ticket the movie but don't
actually say who's calling whom so we
can get some exciting Skype text between
Blair and Mitch I'm not saying the
structure of this film isn't clever but
just because you come up with a clever
idea doesn't mean it needs to be
realized into a white released film mmm
my owner Blair's got some Ray Parker jr.
in this library
why is Blair asking Mitch this question
her previous screen clearly stated that
at 9:00 she added Jess Mitch Adam and
Ken to the conversation also she was
already in a conversation with Mitch
doing her striptease routine so why
would it say she added him along with
the other three come on newbie if you're
gonna Skype Skype right really Blair
it's been two seconds he's not ghosting
you I know we're in a movie but give a
guy at least a full minute before you
start going all overly attached
girlfriend on his ass how about I call
Blaire back and then we'll go from there
seriously we're doing another callback
this movie really needs to start on
fronting the most unbelievable part of
this movie is the ability of these kids
to type nearly flawlessly without using
autocorrect
I mean look Blair even used the correct
version of who's and ended a sentence
with the punctuation oh where did the
previous messages go she originally
responded that's not funny
and he said I'm serious now those are
gone so how am I supposed to know if it
was funny or if he was serious and now
the message is back again
I get that the ghost of Laura Barnes is
messing with them but I'm pretty sure
this one has less to do with her and
more to do with the ghost of the
continuity department if today's the
one-year anniversary of Laura suicide
which we know happened April 12 2013
then this movie should be happening
Saturday April 12 2014 but Blair's
computer says today is Monday so neither
her computer's broken or the filmmakers
don't think I know how to read a
calendar
why can't we continue to hear the Skype
conversation that's obviously still
going on behind this window or whatever
the Mac version of a window is called
the professor probably actually killed
herself because none of her teaching was
getting through to anyone considering
whomever posted this couldn't even
capitalize the lead of the sentence no
one will be seated during Blair's
detailed reporting at a lower Barnes
account hacker also as interesting as
this concept is I'd be lying if I said
there aren't many moments of sheer
boredom as we watch someone simply
navigate the internet if this has been a
short film maybe they could have cut out
a lot of the digital downtime which
still uses the mouse to select the copy
function if you weren't using command or
control C and V for all your cut and
paste needs you may actually deserve
what's coming to you in this movie troll
credit and now we can hear the Skype
conversation again sure it might be
distracting to listen to whatever was
going on in this teenage talk fest but
it's a little more distracting to have a
computer that randomly decides to play
audio only when it's convenient ooh the
plot
well Ken I don't like you and I really
don't understand how you joey fatone
your way into this group trashy little
bitch bleep damn it I think we've hit on
a new formula for the real world saves a
lot on production costs I guess and we
can go fight outside of a Wendy's or
something to be fair to Val all the
pictures are on justice page so it makes
perfect sense to assume she posted them
no one is aware there was a supernatural
presence at work yet you said it was
just a glitch hi
the teenage dialog in this movie makes
my soul to take sound like classic
Pinter probably just like a troll or
something a troll that has Laura's
actual account what is it troll this
question only makes me wish that there
were still people in 2018 that didn't
know what a troll is I have to sign with
Billy two to seven here there's already
been 250 scenes in less than 30 minutes
of them hanging up and calling everybody
back there's a third I'm gonna go all
unfriended up in this joint come over
Adam we'll go see Kyle we'll go across
the tracks across the tracks man this is
what you get when you rely too much on
an improper form it's Oh for the love of
jobs Skype throws up a pop-out window
when she navigates away this time
apparently Blaire just upgraded to the
version of Skype with the enhanced AI
integration for maximum dramatic tension
fortunately Ken would be excellent at
cinemasins
just send it to Ken so we can find out
who it is Kenda has been zero help with
the whole Billy to 2/7 thing he thought
it was a fucking glitch
why in the hell do they think he can
figure this out okay either I'm going
crazy or there's no forwarding button so
the ghost somehow eliminated Blair's
ability to forward in Gmail sure lore
has been grave hacking other things too
but the difference here is that this
hack exists only so that she has to
share her screen for the plots benefit
and for no other ghostly reason
shouldn't say that stuff and you
shouldn't forget that you never close
down screen share and he and everyone
can still see what you're doing except
the movie doesn't seem to care either
and considering it'll never come up
again why should any of us goddamnit
they're still on the Skype call like
Mitch is right in there just me asking
what's coming on Luby's idea of tension
and suspense is this scene I was more
afraid when Jeremy corner was waiting to
figure out if he'd keep a client when he
went solo the original tagline for this
movie 5250 actually Blair you're
highlighting 51 50 and honestly I'm
gonna go full 51 50 if we don't start
moving this along very soon also why is
care Blair even highlighting things as
she's reading them except for our
benefit at some point this whole thing
started to feel like a morbid PowerPoint
presentation
nobody except no one exactly maybe a
Mitch even if it's not a virus you know
it's not going to be anything good plus
if you leave it alone the movie would be
over so let's just finish this damn it
Blair as if I don't get frustrated
enough waiting for files to download in
real life now I'm going to movies to
watch it happen does this movie I'm an
uninstall feature also if you're skyping
with us many people this easily there is
no way one megabyte photo download
should take this long I actually don't
know since all these assholes are still
essentially nameless to me at this point
and I just assume they're all horrible
people
cyber saw we already know this is
supposed to be April 12 so why is all
Blair's recent email from mid-october
it's all of those in an empty recycling
bin okay pretty sure not okay just
couldn't even figure out how to delete
facebook photographs Claire didn't know
what a troll was this crew doesn't seem
like an effective group of children
virus detection launchers haha yes nice
work Ken no need to check on Val or
anything until we revel in your ability
to get this annoying user off our group
Skype ah-ha-ha damn when did Mitch
become Billy from scream all of a sudden
what so Laura is somehow answering for
911 now with the real human voice she
moved from possessing laptops to
possessing random 9-1-1 operators will
any of these things even try to make
sense okay
can I guess Ken would say that can
conveniently getting up at the exact
moment is convenient why is the action
of Ken moving boxes so loud on Blairs
computer his computer is on the other
side of the room let's assume there's a
headphone mic picking up some of the
noise it still wouldn't be that loud 30
seconds of Ken steering also I swear
this movie pauses in moments for so long
that I sometimes wonder if the
screenwriters brains are buffering so
does a medieval aura have the ability to
kick them offline why would she want to
exactly are her abilities and why wait
until the anniversary to do all this how
did she even know they would all be on a
group call on the suicide anniversary
why is this movie 25% people
disconnecting calls why did everyone
except for Blair wait for Ken to freak
out to appear on screen is Blair's
computer the only one that has a flair
for dramatic timing 47 minutes in and
I'm actually excited to see Ken's hand
and a blender since it means at least
something has been happened goddamnit
these are kids who have been raised with
mobile devices as their primary tool and
none of them are using it to do anything
after that call text call use the
flashlight the movie wants to use that
9-1-1 fake out from a few moments ago
was an out to eliminate the phones and
I'm not buying it especially after they
know for a fact that someone died there
was no group of teens that wouldn't be
trying to reach out to all sorts of
people as this was happening even after
a weird 9-1-1 call yeah well if there's
no one there then what exactly are you
checking out also are no one's parents
at home sure Blaire and Mitch's dad's
are up drinking together but there are
no other mothers in this universe when
Blair selects the force quit tab and the
video doesn't disappear immediately why
does the sound clearly shows in the
front youtube video that the sound has
not been muted why do these two videos
that look to be in the exact same spot
show time codes that are eight seconds
apart also it's pretty fitting that in
the end this movie's inciting incident
is literally Jesus I know teens could be
assholes but suggesting someone should
kill themselves over themselves well
passed out drunk is this the same school
from wrinkle and time also if all these
messages were being sent then why was
Val criticized so much earlier in the
movie for the email suggesting Laura do
the exact same thing is Blair actually
trying to get information from a pink
don't talk to dead people reddit also
apparently this sentence construction
has also been possessed somebody just
tell me how to play thunder you
my fingers and then if you've done
something you have to put your finger
now actually that's just one way to play
never have I ever you can also drink
every time you've done the D or remove
an item of clothing since Billy two to
seven is giving no directions then let's
hope Jessa's version is the one she
wants them to play or they're all dead
why are you why but Blair just confessed
to posting about Laura and that they
were all doing it so why don't they just
come clean now
don't they all know what they did based
on the previous 55 minutes of this film
pretty sure that would have only been
one of many reasons Adams dad should
disown it this little game I've never
have I ever is bringing up some sore
spots among these four but doesn't that
seem a bit strange to start turning on
one another when this kind of weird is
going down I'm signing with Blair here
she's the one person who has done
nothing to Adam during this game why
didn't he go after Jess or Mitch - Blair
just assumed mitch is seeing this - no
one else is complained about their
screens getting hijacked and he didn't
say a thing about it also who even took
this video
where was it stored and how did it get
uploaded so fast did Laura work as part
of the Geek Squad before she died also
also why are every one of these videos
edited damn I guess they just let any
kind of smut on YouTube these days those
unscrupulous bastards but why has a
Billy 2 to 7 killed any of them yet they
keep taking their hands down and how
would any of them remember how many
fingers they should still have up in all
this confusion it's calm down okay just
a quick reminder it's been 15 minutes
since these members of the teenage
wasteland saw a friend die and still
none of them have even thought to use
their readily available phones for any
purpose whatsoever how about not show
with a paper that gets one of your good
friends killed I mean I've never been in
a situation where me and four of my
friends were held hostage by a ghost
that has a fondness for finger pants but
I'm pretty sure I would do the exact
opposite of everything these dumbasses
have done so far also what the hell this
pop-up ad feels so out of place here
that I'm wondering if it's only meant to
cover up something in the background
they didn't like and yes I do realize
there's a bit of Blair unbuttoning or
sure taniad but I still feel like the
tone is way off you're in a life or
death situation friends are dying and
you have your phone nearby and you're
opening
Roulet to save the day do you want
penises player because that's how you
get penises the ghost in the machine has
shown the ability to impact any area of
these computers that she wants so why is
she leaving this chat completely
unaffected dear god this constant signal
degrade effect is annoying I know it's
supposed to be scary but it's more
likely that's just meant as a way to
hide necessary cuts either way
eventually I'd like to actually see or
hear what's going on okay does your
phone not have a flashlight
why is everyone continuing to ignore the
best tool in the toolbox time and place
player time and place if Laura has been
possessing everyone else to kill
themselves why is she all the sudden
physically manifesting to kill Blair
also isn't this movie a hundred times
better if it sticks to its guns and
takes place entirely on the computer
screen and maybe ends with an empty
skype room or maybe Laura deleting files
and covering her tracks you got the ball
of the one-yard line movie why fumble
now
get the knife what the knife you have
part of my attention you have the
minimum amount hello do you wanna play
Akane that's gonna leave a mark
oh hello